foreign
a few years ago well I guess it's been
six or seven years now since we moved
from Montana to California Ryan we moved
to sunny Southern California the first
thing I did is says I don't need this
rain jacket anymore and you know me I
keep all my I have so many jackets yeah
my wife calls me a jacket oh yeah
yeah uh I have like six jackets as a
minimalist it's like the one thing but I
they fit within my 90-90 rule but the
one thing I got rid of because I'm like
we're in sunny Southern California it
never rains in southern California wrong
it does rain and so I got rid of my rain
jacket part of it was symbolic I'm done
with Montana let me get away from the
rain I'm not gonna need this rain jacket
and then over the last few weeks we have
had record setting more rain and uh than
any other time in our lifetime in
Southern California my crawl space has
flooded several times I've had to sump
pump things out it's been a disaster and
I I also don't have a rain jacket
so this is one of those things where
it's like it was appropriate for me to
let go of it for a period of time
because I got by fine without it for a
while but then I realized you know what
I do need a rain jacket as a just for
win item and it may be once or twice a
year that I really need it for heavy
rains when I'm going out to fix
something in the yard or whatever but it
makes sense to have this for a period of
time even if it doesn't fit within my
seasonality rule even if it's not a just
in case item it is a just for win item
because I know even in Southern
California I'm gonna need that rain
jacket every once in a while yeah
eventually
did you enjoy this Standalone patreon
highlight if so you can listen to full
episodes of the minimalist private
podcast available exclusively on patreon
visit patreon.com the minimalists or
click the link in the description your
support keeps our podcast and YouTube
Channel 100
advertisement free